c'est une petite ville du Midwest
devenue célèbre au petit comme au grand
écran
Go à inspirer le film culte qui porte
son nom
Ivy depuis presque 27 ans
sa ville n'a rien à voir avec celle dont
le film policier
1600 de plus en plus comme une
criminelle
depuis avril l'avortement est presque
complètement interdit au Dakota du Nord
Camille était propriétaire de la seule
clinique de l'état du jour au lendemain
son métier est devenu illégal
camille a dû fermer sa clinique mais il
n'a pas baissé les bras pour autant
le combat de l'Américaine s'est déplacé
à quelques kilomètres à l'est au
Minnesota voisin ou l'avortement est
toujours permis avec peu de restriction
chaque matin tamis franchit la rivière
qui sépare les deux états une dizaine de
minutes de voiture pour se rendre dans
sa nouvelle clinique à mon aide
famille a déménagé avant que le Dakota
du Nord ne criminalise officiellement
l'avortement
aujourd'hui la salle d'attente est
déserte les patientes ne sont reçus que
les mercredis mais il y a parfois des
urgences à gérer
au téléphone avec une clinique de
Chicago
qu'elle ne pouvait pas voir mais il y a
un problème avec le paiement
c'était un gros feu à éteindre
des filles logistiques
Destiny aussi à l'habitude d'éteindre
des feux la jeune femme gère un fond qui
offre une aide financière aux femmes qui
ont besoin de voyager pour leur
avortement
en avril et ont mis l'organisme a donné
environ 50000 dollars à des patientes
une somme importante mais suffisante
face à l'ampleur des besoins
Destiny insiste pour nous emmener dans
un commerce du centre-ville de Fargo un
sanctuaire progressiste dans cet état
conservateur
la jeune femme tenait à nous montrer
cette autre visage de sa ville en
sachant bien que son point de vue est
minoritaire
sur la route qui sépare Fargo de
Bismarck la capitale de l'État on voit
bien la présence de cette ultra
conservatisme kilomètres après
kilomètres des panneaux anti-avortement
surtout comment dites par des groupes
religieux
est souvent décrite comme la voix de ces
groupes au Capitole
le gouvernement doit protéger toute vie
potentielle affirme la sénatrice
républicaine Johana espère que plus
d'états adopteront des lois
anti-avortement mais en attendant elle
n'a pas l'intention de criminaliser les
déplacements à l'extérieur du Dakota
du Minnesota le Dakota du Nord partage
une longue frontière avec le Manitoba
le centre de santé des femmes de
Winnipeg a d'ailleurs déjà accueilli des
patientes américaines
de la clinique elle ne veut pas chiffrer
ce phénomène ses employés sont inquiets
d'éventuels représailles aux États-Unis
ou ressources limitées mais ce n'est pas
l'afflux de clientes américaines qui
inquiète mais plutôt l'arrivée d'un
certain discours en provenance des
États-Unis
pendant ce temps à Fargo on s'habitue à
la réalité posturaux dans cinq clinique
d'avortement héberge maintenant un
collectif d'artistes et tamis est
toujours propriétaire du bâtiment
de temps en temps elles iront pour
récupérer son courrier un rappel de sa
bataille perdue
comme plusieurs militantes au choix
Camille refuse de s'avouer vaincu elle
tient bon entre les allers-retours
incessants et les manifestations
anti-avortement devant sa clinique
le fait pour ses patientes qui viennent
de plus en plus loin dans un pays
toujours plus fracturé ou la question de
l'avortement ne semble jamais tout à
fait régler